it's not the best episode for her Brina
I'm just gonna say that it's
heartbreaking
it totally is I mean I loved them
[Music]
welcome back witches and happy solstice
now we must have all been on the nice
list because the Dark Lord has gifted us
with an extra episode of chilling
Adventures of Sabrina just in time for
the holidays praise Satan or Santa or
both right Yuletide Spellman's it's time
to conjure up some fun because I have
new interviews from Kiernan Shipka and
Ross Lynch spilling exclusive secrets
about Harvey and Sabrina's post solstice
relationship status I hope you
understand of course her be by the end
of the holiday special it seemed like
Sabrina and Harvey were even more broken
up what was your reaction when you read
that in the script I mean obviously
heart broke and I'm a heart Brina
shipper as much as anyone elses I was
reading the script and I was like Harvey
cuz I'm like you know I had that
reaction too as a fan yeah you want him
to be okay with with with the magic so
their magic I'd say enchanted but I
wanted to yell at Harvey through the
screen was it's just colored pencils
come on I can't keep these it really
seems like this kind of put the nail in
their coffin would you agree no I don't
agree there's always gonna be a little
bit of a spark between them I think that
they're wonderful and and even if
eventually they do end up getting back
together and nothing will be like Harvey
and Sabrina season 1 I'm more than that
yeah RIT that because truly that was
such a special innocent young love sort
of thing that is a thing of the past
without care oh my god this is about
care just watching the Night of the
Living Dead they can never look back at
doctor services and that will never
happen yet they both seem too much and
too much at this point I did it to help
me I know
just like I did with Tommy I don't
Justice Sabrina it's a moment of letting
go for them and a moment of separation
and in the next part of season one we
really see them coming into their own
and finding themselves in new ways in
ways that separate the more and bring
them back together more and it's a bit
of a back and forth there'll be some
romance that kicks up in a few episodes
later between abrino but there's also
some romance that kicks up between some
other characters on the show all right
which is you know what to do give this
video a like and then cast your spell in
the comments below what do you think
about this emotional twist for Harvey
and Sabrina do you think they're still
endgame or would you like to see them
brew up some romance with someone new
thank you so much for watching witches
and I hope you and your cousin have a
happy solstice later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]